paolo levi correspondant à paris de l'
agence de presse anne ça bonjour bonsoir
photo paul levy merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors le sommet
un qui a un petit peu changé de tournure
en pleine crise du coronavirus le
président micron qui a tenu quand même à
maintenir ce sommet c'est un message
important de solidarité envers les
italiens président français se soit
rendu là bas c'est un message très très
important d'ailleurs qui a été reconnue
cet après midi même par le miz affaires
étrangères italien luigi di maio qui a
tenu à remercier personnellement le
président de la république m'a cran et
tout le gouvernement français pour être
venus en grand nombre à naples parce que
cela signifie aussi un message très
important la communauté internationale
sur le fait que l'italie n'est pas un
pays à risque et que la vie doit
continuer donc continuer à venir en
italie c'est pas du tout en se
renfermant lancé propre pays respectifs
combat combattre le virus
la solution saas est vrai aussi mais il
ya quand même des informations
contradictoires les autorités françaises
diffusent d'ailleurs des des communiqués
dans les écoles un petit peu partout
pour dire voilà on déconseille quand
même de voyager dans les pays à risque
on dit d'ailleurs au aux écoliers de qui
se sont rendus en italie du nord dans
les périodes dans les régions touchées
de ne pas venir à l'école pendant 14
jours votre passion du mans c'est très
très important de 2
de le rappeler parce qu'aujourd'hui on
s'apprête à vivre des mois assez
difficiles assez inédit en europe mais
je pense dans le monde entier et donc il
faut être faire preuve de bon sens pour
que ce virus cette épidémie puisse se
propager le moins possible et donc c'est
la responsabilité de nos dirigeants
politiques mais aussi de nous mêmes en
tant qu'individu juste de faire preuve
de bon sens de se laver les mains
d'élite et voilà les grands
rassemblements comme par exemple un
match de foot etc pour pour que ce virus
se puisse vite s'estomper mais sur de
futures un lion hier piétonnier écouter
non je ne suis pas étonné parce que dès
lors qu'on maintient les vols en
provenance de la chine dès lors qu'on
laisse les frontières ouvertes etc
on fait un choix et ce choix est tout à
fait compréhensible mais enferme pas un
stade
certes après la contradiction est dans
le fait par exemple que les élèves qui
reviennent de longues parties doivent se
prêter à une quarantaine donc c'est à
dire c'est soit soit l'autre mais les
deux choses ensemble parfois la
communication est un peu confuse mais
c'est pas pour cela qu'il faut il faut
qu'on d'amener les actions de nos
dirigeants politiques dans le pays parce
qu'on est en train de vivre quelque
chose de complètement inédit et donc
tous aujourd'hui on a un devoir de de
tester et aussi de responsabilité donc
vous êtes entre les deux pays en tout
cas vous emmanuel macron n'a pas fait
mention de défaillance possible dans la
gestion du coronavirus en italie où tu
es en italie il n'y a pas eu de
défaillance particulière il ya juste eu
une grosse grosse un gros manque de
chance c'est à dire que notre patient
numéro 1 qui n'avait pas une
manifestation claire et nette de lettres
porteurs de ce virus s'est présenté dans
un hôpital et il a infecté des gens plus
vulnérables qui était dans l'hôpital et
de la ce a explosé en embardée
c'est un peu on va le voir si les
enquêtes vont le confirmer mais c'est un
peu ce qui est en train de se passer
aussi en france avec le patient qui est
décédé à la pitié salpêtrière et qui
avait été dans l'oise hospitalisé au
paravant c'est un petit peu la même
chose donc la chose à mon avis qui est
aussi la responsabilité de nounous les
médias c'est de répéter jusqu'à l'ennui
que si on a un petit doute
on ne doit pas aller aux urgences on
doit pas aller à l'hôpital mais juste
appeler le 15
n'était le samu bien la maison il
vérifie qu on a juste une crypte et pas
de coronavirus et on est tous
tranquilles et on évite de propager
voilà la maladie chez des gens plus
vulnérables parce que pour le faut le
rappeler ce virus dans 80 % des cas et
même plus c'est absolument bénin on le
vit juste comme une normale créé mais il
ya des personnes vulnérables qui peuvent
avoir des ce qu'elle bien plus grave et
donc il faut éviter de les comptages et
donc en tout cas une entente un très
cordiale entre emmanuel macron un
premier ministre italien aujourd'hui
c'était important c'est que la relation
franco italienne a connu des hauts et
des bas ces derniers temps ces derniers
mois c'était important d'afficher cette
entente retrouvée et écouter oui parce
que on a vécu l'année dernière notamment
des mois très très lourd avec cette
guerre verbale mais pas moins fratricide
entre deux pays frères de l'europe est
donc aujourd'hui les choses ont changé
matteo salvini et
le dirigeant de la ligue est sorti du
gouvernement et on essaye voilà de de
célébrer aujourd'hui cette
réconciliation franco italienne vous
savez on a beau changer l'histoire mais
on ne change pas la géographie la france
et l'italie resteront à jamais de
voisins de palier donc autant aller dans
l'entente parce que on sait tous que
quand on s'entend pas bien avec les
voisins y compris leur nos immeubles
parisiens c'est très sympa je croyais
pas si bien dire
est-ce qu'on peut désormais dire avec ce
nouveau gouvernement compte et que paris
et rome sont à nouveau sur la même ligne
mais écoutez ça dépend des dossiers être
toujours sur la même ligne je dirais
même que c'est presque un lieu plus
évident mais oui absolument mais il ya
un socle de valeurs fondamentales qui
sont communes et je pense notamment à la
nécessité d'aller de l'avant dans
l'intégration européenne parce que c'est
vraiment ça qui qui anime disons le le
coeur de deux pays fondateurs qui sont
la france et l'italie et et après il ya
plein de dossiers et sur mayotte
migratoire qu'est aussi sait où c'est
d'ailleurs compliqué son tendre avec eux
on en parlera d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
avec les onglets 1 ça se passe
difficilement il faut aussi s'entendre
évidemment avec l'italie pour faire face
à cette nouvelle négociation après le
rex absolument absolument il faut
absolument garder un lien très fort avec
la grande bretagne qui doit rester un
partenaire fondamental c'est pas parce
que sont sortis de l'union européenne
qui là qu'il va arrêter de coopérer avec
l'europe donc ça c'est un dossier très
important il ya notre dossier très
important qui est celui des migrations
et qui voit l'italie en première ligne
aujourd'hui il ya quand même une prise
de conscience de la part de la france
aussi d'autres pays européens qui
pendant une certaine période c'était un
petit peu détournée de la question une
prise de conscience de l'importance de
ce dossier surtout du fait que l'it des
pays comme l'italie
mais je pense même à l'espagne ou à
malte sont en première ligne et donc il
faut
absolument faire preuve de solidarité
parce que voilà tout seul notre petit
état nation en tout cas en europe ne
sont pas en mesure de le faire face aux
grands défis du monde contemporain et la
question migratoire évidemment qui était
partant au sujet donc de ce sommet avec
la mission européenne militaire sofia on
le rappelle ce que s'est créée en 2015
pour lutter contre le réseau de passeurs
en méditerranée sur ce point l'italie
aussi un petit peu le ton 6 alouettes
une soupape un fan je cherche le mot
voilà au provoqué en tout cas l'afflux
d'émigrants ça sera terminé est-ce que
clairement cette mission est en danger
aujourd'hui la liste de s'arrêter on va
voir ce niveau européen que se joue ce
je pense qu'à la fin on va trouver
certainement un compromis sur ça aussi
c'est une question trop importante
aujourd'hui pour que les nations
européennes soient divisés sur ce thème
là et quoique les flux migratoires ont
baissé ces derniers temps c'est toujours
un thème qui risquent de ré exploser à
tout moment et donc la prochaine fois il
faut absolument que l'europe ne soit pas
dépourvu ne se fasse prendre de court
par un parent cette question faut
trouver un équilibre entre voit la
solidarité et rigueur par rapport remis
cran que malheureusement on peut pas
accueillir et aussi il faut une
solidarité accrue au niveau européen de
répartition parce qu il ya des troubles
il ya certains pays trop de pays
notamment à l'est de l'europe qui
profitent disons des avantages de
l'europe et je pense par exemple à tout
tous les fonds européens et c est en
revanche il ne s'assume pas les devoirs
de solidarité par rapport aux autres
pays donc il faut trouver un bon
équilibre mais on va y arriver c'est
comme dans toutes les bonnes familles
parfois il y à des frictions mais on va
y arriver
neuf ans après on a retrouvé vraiment
cette entente
quand même vous avez senti ça en les
voyant aujourd'hui ils ont besoin les
uns des autres
écoutez cette entente est vraiment une
nécessité
je vous rappelle que la france et
l'italie ont des liens historiques très
très profond
c'est respectivement la france et
l'italie sont les deuxièmes partenaires
commerciaux donc on n'a vraiment pas
intérêt à se brouiller entre nous et ce
sommet aujourd'hui dans cette magnifique
ville de naples avec ce soleil et ce
ciel bleu orné une magnifique
manifestation et représentations merci
beaucoup pour l'eau lévy d'avoir été
avec nous correspondant à paris de l'
agence de presse en deçà merci à vous
merci